I'm an EU citizen,
of course I don't have to
show my passport
when I travel to
other EU countries
I'm an EU citizen,
of course I have the right
to study, work and live
in any of the
27 member states
I'm an EU citizen,
of course it's illegal
to discriminate against me
at work for being gay
– thanks to an EU directive
And the same goes for
all these other
grounds of discrimination
I'm an EU citizen,
of course I can
vote in local elections
no matter where
in the bloc I live,
even if I'm not
a country national
I'm an EU citizen,
of course I don't pay
additional charges to
use my mobile phone
when travelling to
other EU countries
I'm an EU citizen,
of course I love “Dragostea Din Tei”
and think it's our anthem